[Musique]
voici une photo de la première
échographie d'une mère que l'on
appellera isabelle un nom fictif pour
protéger l'identité de son enfant fin
trentaine est toujours célibataire elle
est devenue maman il y a trois ans en
trouvant un donneur de sperme sur
internet qu'il a ainsi miné de façon
dite artisanale c'est qu'ils prennent
données fortement on se ferme dans un
petit pot afin de s'incliner soi même
donc ceci en dehors des annales ya des
sites ou qui met une annonce comme
kijiji base hors du plateau
et puis on a des réponses de donneurs
qui nous contactent grâce à des messages
échangés avec d'autres femmes ayant
aussi reçu un don de sperme
elles soupçonnent que son propre donneur
pourrait être le géniteur d'une
trentaine d'enfants uniquement dans le
grand montréal
vous êtes donc le géniteur de 533
enfants dont 142 d'entre eux veulent
connaître votre identité
c'est un jeu de donneurs de sperme hyper
actif avait d'ailleurs inspiré martin
petit et ken scott dans le film starbuck
sortie en 2011 où le personnage
principal était le géniteur de 533
enfants
joint par radio-canada le géniteur en
question a refusé toutes nos demandes
d'entrevue
est-ce que vous avez réfléchi à notre
proposition d'entrevue en regardant les
annonces sur le site web ou isabelle a
déniché son donneur on se rend compte
qu'elle n'est pas une marginale des
dizaines de femmes ont récemment affiché
une annonce pour trouver elles aussi
donneur de sperme jeunes professionnels
de 34 ans cherche donneur de sperme pour
mener à terme mon rêve de maternité
disponible pour méthodes artisanales
seulement des annonces qui viennent de
partout au québec
bonjour je suis de sherbrooke et cherche
un donneur artisanale sérieux je suis
une jeune femme il ya 33 ans avec une
jeune ado de 14 ans et j'aimerais bien
finalisés je cherche un donneur de
sperme qui vit dans mon coin de pays
je cherche un donneur qui pourrait
ressembler un peu à mon copain
mélodie et la vie d'isabelle leur amitié
est née parce qu'elle a été approchée
sur le web par le même géniteur que
celui d'isabelle l'anonymat c'est pour
protéger son futur enfant
dans le cas de mélodies ce sont les
coups qui ont joué dans sa décision
c'est que l'insémination assisté en
clinique de fertilité n'est pas
totalement gratuite
l'acte entente elle ne coûte rien c'est
couvert par la ramq jusqu'à 9 la
paillette parcs tél c'est en ça va
arriver dépendamment si on prend un don
d'une banque externe des états unis
qu'il faut faire venir des fois il faut
payer notre reportage pour payer s'ils
ont vu une densité ouverte tout ça ça
peut varier de 700 parfois peut-être
même à 909 la fois un set en deux lors
une fois par mois
calculant que pour beaucoup beaucoup ça
ne faudrait un peu du premier on fait le
calcul c'est que en iran des spots et
qui maison les deux femmes prises de
silence pour que les politiciens
prennent conscience de l'importance de
ce marché parallèle qui s'est créé
malgré l'interdiction de la loi fédérale
sur la procréation assistée
c'est surtout si ce côté il a compté
maladie côté est et côté moral c'est
particulier nous avons contacté santé
canada qui affirme avoir pris
connaissance de la distribution de
sperme sur internet il ya une dizaine
d'années deux avertissements ont été
émis en 2010 et 2011 pour mettre en
garde les futures mères des risques
importants pour leur santé et celle des
enfants à naître
le ministère précise que la loi
prévoyait la mise sur pied d'une agence
canadienne chargée de tenir un registre
national des donneurs mais le projet a
été annulé à la suite d'une décision de
la cour suprême
le plus haut tribunal a jugé que ce
registre était plutôt de compétence
provinciale le droit sont pas justes
droits et souvent réactif qui tardent
souvent à bien encadrer des réalités qui
sociale qui évolue très rapidement
emmanuel marceau considère que ses
revendications auprès des politiciens
sont légitimes mais la question n'est
pas simple
on a fait le choix pour l'instant dans
notre société de préserver l'anonymat
des donneurs
mais de l'autre côté bon pour les mères
et pour les enfants à m bassil le droit
à l'information la transparence et le
dans le cas des dons multiples d'un
donneur et ça peut avoir aussi des
répercussions son enfant mettre ne
serait-ce qu'au niveau du bagage
génétique
santé canada ti est actuellement des
consultations publiques pour moderniser
la loi sur la procréation assistée
mais le droit à l'anonymat d'un donneur
de sperme et le droit à l'information
des enfants à naître ne sont pas inclus
dans le projet